this video is sponsored by space leaper
more on it later
the numbers don't lie you've all spoken
you like those dynamic entry vids so
it's only natural that we move on to the
next category of the list mentors join
the fray in today's list as we'll go
through what i think are the most
legendary entrances made by anime
mentors because while the protagonist
gets a time to shine we all know it's
the mentor who gets most of the cool
stuff from the get-go so let's take a
look at some of my favorite and most
memorable anime mentor entrances
[Music]
let's start with raley's entrance
[Music]
they sure sold this moment big time
without everyone's just staring helpless
to stop gizaru's attack you know
something's about to happen the whole
thing is obviously setting up for a big
moment waiting to happen and i'm glad it
did seeing the camera follow rayleigh
soaring through the air as he interrupts
gizaru surely got people out of their
seats makes you wonder how prime really
would have been a pure nightmare to deal
with i'm sure
before we move on to the next entry
here's a game to be excited about
introducing today's sponsor space
sleeper cocoon space sleeper cocoon is a
mobile game that takes place in a
post-apocalyptic world but not one that
you might expect instead of settling for
the barren wastelands of earth society
has taken past the skies and into outer
space on the spaceship called cocoon
it's up to you an unwary youngster who
accidentally connected to the cocoon
system to lead a gang of cute anamorphic
girls through the wildest explorations
through space and time space sleeper is
one of the latest in the line of fun
auto battler games you can get on mobile
i've been playing for quite a while now
it's been a blast the first thing i love
is how it feels and looks so fun it's a
quirky contender that boasts graphics
that harken back to the good old days of
retro gaming thanks to the sleek clean
art style that's both cute and
eye-catching a new game that's set to
take the world by storm space sleeper is
now open for pre-registration be the
first in line and get some amazing perks
and rewards the game is available both
on ios and android and his grand launch
will be in august so hurry up because
pre-registration time is running out
fast a fantastic world of fun and
excitement awaits only in space leaper
the link's in the description we don't
need to look too far back for our next
entry courtesy of tengen uzui
demon slayer continued its role from the
triumphant conquest of 2019 but it's
still one of the biggest shonen out
there and continued to impress with the
master class in presentation i could
talk about the fights the sound
direction and the animation the whole
day but we're here for badass entrances
and i think tengen saving the group is a
candidate that's short and sweet the
display of quick slashes that saved his
wives zenitsu and inosuke was pure hype
tengen's appearance in the ark's boss
fight can count as another moment to add
to this list but i feel that this one
was just more impactful from the swift
dispatching of enemies to the hype
visual of him appearing from the smoke
this one seems to be the better choice
most of the pillars had impactful
entries into battle but while some have
a shade of coolness or mystery i feel
there's none as purely badass as
tengen's moment in season two
yami's entrance versus vetto is another
legendary entrance
just how badass can a mentor be yami's
the character who puts that to the test
he just oozes badass energy as well as
those edgy attacks and gruff attitude a
true mentor amped for a group like the
black balls oh and he knows how to make
a perfect entrance too just like when he
finishes the job against vetto the black
balls have proven their worth but the
fight's not over thankfully they have
someone as powerful as yami to finish it
on a personal note i like how he has it
in him to complement his comrades a
great show of leadership from someone as
powerful and high up as him even better
is how this whole moment sets up a
complete round courtesy of my favorite
captain while the black balls had their
hands full against vetto yami easily
destroys him in a matter of seconds the
squad is just as strong as their captain
and looking at yami we all know these
young upstarts are in good hands
minato's entrance in the war deserves a
mention here
talk about a tide turner against the
might of the ten tails there's just no
hope for the protagonist shikamaru can
strategize all he wants but everyone's
combined mike gets brushed aside by the
ten tails attack that is until the
legendary minato arrives and along with
the entrance comes the disruption of the
seemingly unstoppable attack and of
course it's never a dull moment with
monato as the tension cools down for
some short comedy just as you'd expect
from someone so badass yes so chill like
monato still his heroic entry led the
way for the whole gargay to join the
fray and this is where everything
changes this is where the tide turns and
thanks to the spectacular entrance
everyone watching knows it all might
shows why he's the beacon of hope in one
of his early appearances
[Music]
hero academia's first season ended as
well as we all hoped with our plucky
students locked in the fight of their
lives struggling for survival against
the toughest challenge they've had to
face so far there's no shortage of drama
and there's a lot of tense moments it'll
look like it could go either way at one
point but the heroes could only hold out
for so long eventually the villains
triumph and it soon looks like all hope
is lost but as the saying goes it's
never over till it's over and all mike
comes out with one of the best saves in
shown in anime all might entrance really
evokes that redeeming feeling of
salvation after the long struggle the
heroes can finally rest as their
almighty savior has arrived the speech
about how light shines in darkness is
nothing short of awesome as is the
beatdown he single-handedly delivers the
brightest heroes come out in the darkest
of times and all might manifest that
belief in this amazing entrance one that
caps off a great start to one of the
biggest shonen series that we have right
now
izumi makes an entrance that will
[Music]
for the little screen time she has does
make it all count especially with
dynamic entries like these knocking
sloth out like that's gotta count for
something right even armstrong's face
says it all the subsequent fight is both
exciting and funny as well making this
entry a prelude to such a memorable
moment it's both awesome to see
armstrong get another hallmark win under
his belt and it's quite funny that it's
in the form of a team up between two of
the manliest characters in the show
she's already done this once saving ed
from greed but she does it again as we
approach the end game and this moment
featuring her coming with her husband is
even sweeter
[Music]
remember the moment when a call for
kenshin summoned someone else
[Music]
that same call did get help but yahiko
got more than what he bargained for when
it's hiko who comes to help instead of
getting kenshin it's the overpowered
master to the rescue and the look on
everyone's face says it all the
legendary hiko seijuro has descended to
grace everyone with its presence it
doesn't have a lot of the big modern
techniques to artificially increase hype
however for something done in the 90s
the anime team came out with something
that has aged well from the camera
angles to the character's reactions to
the sheer bad ass pose hiko had made
with his legendary entrance it's more
than an apt prelude to the ass kicking
that's about to commence arrogant as he
may sound hiko sure can back it up
though and he made sure to prove that
with the one-sided stomp against the
gigantic fuji
gojo enters the fray in a big way
the hanami fight is one of my personal
highlights in jiu jitsu kaizen it's got
everything shonen fans would want from a
show spectacular animation fight
choreography that's nothing short of
amazing given the importance of the
fight and a lot of character building
being done in the process one thing that
helps elevate this fight to be one of
the best the series has to offer is how
the fight progresses and how it ends
it's well paced giving our characters
their respective moments to shine they
get a lot of their moves in and we see
the fruits of aoe and yuji's bond it
also ends in what i feel is the best way
it could have ended with gojo finally
stepping in and wowing us with hollow
purple it's nice to see how gojo retains
his overpowered status this far into the
season he's truly a force to be reckoned
with and the fight ending the moment he
comes in with this over-the-top
technique further proves that point yey
finishing up our list is dragon dive
is there a mental entrance more spine
tingling and goosebumping juicing than
this one with how zeno showed off this
technique in his and netero's entrance
i'd say that this moment is nothing but
glorious seeing dragon dive wreck the
palace and caused all hell to break
loose is a surreal moment but it's only
preparing us for the amazing fights
we've yet to see in the chimera
antarctic netero is one of the most
beloved mentors in the world of shonen
anime and someone like him deserves
nothing less for an entrance this marks
the point where things get real in this
arc and there's no better prelude than
something this eye-popping these people
know how to make a statement and boy did
they do so in one of the most legendary
ways possible
[Music]
and those are my top mental entrances in
shonen anime that just about wraps up
the list but i think we can add more to
the list do you care to give me any of
your suggestions you can do that in the
comments section or on social media
after all vinnie tube has a lot of
social media avenues discord instagram
patreon all the links are posted and can
be accessed oh so easily and don't
forget to check out the sponsors of this
video space leaper the links in the
description that's it for today hope you
had fun and i'll be looking forward to
seeing you again once again don't forget
to like subscribe and share thanks and
i'll see you next time
you